is about to speak to the media we'll
cross to her live
it's a Time
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's a legal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth I was
elected by the conservative party with a
mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills on on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
well that was Liz truss the UK prime
minister announcing that she will be
stepping down she said I cannot deliver
the Mandate that she promised as leader
that she has spoken to King Charles III
to notify him that she is resigning and
that she has agreed there will be a
leadership election within the next week
so uh that the country can remain on a
path of economic stability Charlie we're
going to bring you back in now uh you're
in Westminster Charlie Angela I guess it
was inevitable that she was basically
had no other option but to step down
today
well we knew that the next 24 hours were
going to be critical we knew things were
going to move fast I don't think and
that many people anticipated it would
move quite this fast Liz truss prime
minister of the UK has just resigned she
has only been in the job for six weeks
and in that time she's seen the pound
plummet she's had to roll back on most
of her policy programs she's had to sack
her Finance Minister kwazi quilting and
yesterday see her home secretary
interior Minister Sue Ella ratherman
resign now that 1922 committee has now
decided that she has not got the Mandate
of her party she is not capable of
leading this government and so she will
they will be looking for another leader
the question now is who there is not
enough consensus within the conservative
party to pick another leader they are
going to have to pull together very
quickly to heal all those divisions and
to come to some consensus not only for
the sake of the party but for the sake
of the country this is a country that
has seen
um it's its economy internal in the last
weeks because of government actions
a resigning prime minister is only going
to Spook the market and what's needed
right now is stability
she said that they have agreed that
there will be a leadership election in
the next week would that be similar do
you think to the one that we saw Liz
truss you to be elected and and I guess
that's a very condensed time frame to to
find a a new prime minister
so it's very very early days early
minutes but as we understand it we would
not be going seeing the same kind of
leadership contest as we saw over the
summer that was a very long lengthy
drawn out process in which all
conservative members of the conservative
party were able to cast their vote on
who they wanted to see leads now I think
what will happen and we'll be able to
bring you more in the next few hours is
that that
decision-making process will be
condensed a couple of candidates will be
put forward and one will be chosen and
and that's not just for the sake of the
party like I said but also for the sake
of the country this country cannot waste
any more time on the the political
infighting that is going on in the
conservative party there are bigger jobs
to be done we have now had the third
interior Ministry in in seven weeks it's
just in term minister in seven weeks
someone needs to be getting on with the
job of dealing with the National
Security of this country dealing with
the economy of this country and this
musical chairs that conservative past
been playing with the different cabinet
seats cannot go on so stability is
needed and I think a conservative party
leadership contest will be condensed
absolutely
who do you think the front runner could
be will it be uh Rishi suneck who
obviously challenged her for the
leadership and lost out last time
uh
again only time will tell some of the
names that are on people's lips at the
moment are penny mordant who was also
knocked out quite early in that
leadership contest some people today in
in the parliament itself have accused
Sue Ella bravaman the outgoing Home
Secretary of actually
orchestrating her own exit just so she
could throw her hat back in the ring for
leadership once again now one of the
reasons that she clashed so much with
Liz truss it was on immigration she
wants to tighten immigration trust
wanted to relax it so that will be a
major consideration for the rest of the
party another name on people's lips is
as you said Rishi sunad
he could have the benefit of perhaps
predicting the economic mess that the UK
is now in he did that was one of his
platforms saying that if trust was to
become leader and put her policies
forward along with her then Finance
Minister quasi quatang that the uh the
the British economy would suffer which
it has so um he might be seen as more of
a safe Pair of Hands on that front so
those are just three names at the moment
um Nadine Doris uh because of MP today
in Parliament has been calling for the
return of Boris Johnson I think we would
be in a very desperate situation if we
were to see a Johnson come back I don't
think he's actually even in the country
at the moment
um but yes four names again as I said
just shows that the indecision within
the conservative party that not one name
is coming to the top
there's been calls from members of the
public that there should be a general
election uh I mean it seems would appear
that uh with uh Liz truss stepping uh
down and a leadership election within
the um conservative party to take place
in the next week that that's unlikely to
happen is there any chance that uh that
that might happen
well they seem to have just wandered off
from behind me but there were a number
of protesters uh just earlier here
calling for just that a general election
um whether or not
one would be triggered I mean not now if
the conservative party is going to
choose another leader what they're
really really trying to get to is
October the 31st now that is the date
when they're planning on Printing and
Publishing their midterm fiscal strategy
that's the the economic strategy that a
Ben prime minister Finance Minister
quasi quatang hinted at when he first
Unleashed his mini budget now that is
something that they've been trying to
get to they hoped that Liz truss would
stay as leader but until that date but
it looks like that's now not going to
happen I think the chances of a general
election
um we can never we can never rule them
out